good afternoon welcome to sky news today
we start with breaking news and the fbi
says that they have arrested the british
socialite glenn maxwell
on charges relating to the jeffrey
epstein scandal
maxwell who has kept a very low profile
since epstein's death last august was
arrested
in new hampshire jeffrey epstein was
accused of raping
and trafficking underage girls over
nearly two
decades well the charges that she has
been charged with have just been
revealed by the fbi
she's facing six indictments conspiracy
to entice
minors to travel to engage in illegal
sex
acts and also enticing minors to travel
a conspiracy to transport minors with
intent to engage in criminal sex
acts and transporting minors and two
counts of perjury sky's u.s
correspondent cordelia lynch
joins us now um we knew that she had
been
keeping a very low profile but but did
we know that this arrest was imminent
we absolutely didn't i mean this has
taken everyone
by surprise for more than a year
people have been trying to track glenn
maxwell down
and have been unsuccessful in doing so
she has been as you say arrested in new
hampshire
according to nbc news that was in
bedfair
bedford rather that's according to one
person with direct knowledge
of the matter as you say we have six
charges there now glenn maxwell was a
long time
friend and confidant of jeffrey epstein
and i think federal prosecutors will be
very happy uh with this result because
she has evaded them for so long
there had been some sightings of her in
fact in manchester on sea
in new hampshire there had been one
image of her which appeared to show her
um at a um a restaurant
but beyond that there has been very
little indeed
now we were told to expect that
potentially
she would be facing charges of
conspiring with jeffrey epstein
to sexually abuse minors it now appears
that perjury is also added to those
charges quite a long list of things
um maxwell's alleged role just to try
and summarize too it was brought into
sharper
focus last august when court filings
were
unsealed which includes the depositions
from some of jeffrey epstein's former
masseuses
staffers and associates and what they
painted jane was this portrait of
maxwell
as um as jeffrey epstein's sort of
chief enabler if you like that she was
the woman who facilitated
um these crimes that she brought the
woman to
women to jeffrey epstein she was well
known in
new york very much a part of an elite
circle in the 90s she was someone that
you would see
out on the party scene but in recent
months of course
and she has not been visible at all so
this today a very significant
development in the case
and korelu i've been talking just a bit
more information from the fbi about the
perjury charges they're saying that you
purge it herself when she
when she was asked of epstein schemes to
recruit underage girls for sexual
massages and she answered
i don't know what you're talking about
and they've also said that she's
basically been charged
with playing a role in the sexual
exploitation and abuse
of multiple minor girls by jeffrey
epstein that's
in the court papers that we have got
more on that as we as we get it cordelia
thanks very much indeed